We lose friends for a variety of reasons.
People move.
I don't want to move to New York.
But...
they just have better pizza.
You get into fights.
Dude!
How many times do I have to tell you...
that Los Angeles has great pizza?!
Life gets crazy.
We could probably get together on...
Thursday...
of January...
2017...
No matter what the reason,
we all know what it's like to lose a friend,
and...it sucks.
It's kinda like a breakup where you have this period
of being...just sad.
And you wanna call them
and you wanna know where it all went wrong...
and you're mourning, and you're moping,
until finally one day...
you wish them well,
and you move on with your life.
The first step is to self-reflect.
And to try to find something that you learned
from the friendship.
Because something about...mentally learning something
from an experience makes it feel whole. and complete.
And, in essence, finished.
Second, Don't let this experience deter you
from emotionally engaging from other people.
Don't let one experience with someone
completely change how you interact with other people.
And finally,
let yourself feel the feelings.
There are so many times when our past comes up,
and...we just want to push it away.
Or our first instinct is to be like,
"Oh don't think about that! FUCK THAT!
FUCK. THAT."
But, it's important to give yourself permission.
So if you miss someone,
let yourself just miss them.
And, be like, "You know what, that's fine.
I really miss that person, in this moment,
but it's over for a reason."
And let yourself sit with that
for as long as you need to sit with that.
Ultimately, we're all gonna lose a lot of friends
throughout our life.
But we're also gonna gain a lot of friends
and a lot of experiences.
So, it works out! Hey~
Stay awesome, Gotham.
Ha~!
Subtitles by Skylar Coland via Amara